you're right that's how i've written my
first step
okay place the compass point on before i
go over there
what is the second step what do i do
once my compass point is there
i have to draw two things don't i
first i want to draw an arc that will
intersect with a b
see why we introduced all this language
so we can actually describe what's going
on okay so
draw an arc that intersects
with a b
okay so let me quickly do that
now by the way you might have noticed uh
it's probably easier with yours
actually no yours don't have titanium it
really helps if
you try and make sure that your compass
stays the same width all the way through
like you don't accidentally go
as you're drawing a knife you go whoa
whoopsie daisy right because that'll
mess up all of the diagrams and you
your lines won't end up parallel okay so
let me draw it through now
my third step is i have to draw another
arm
where does the other arc go
someone else someone doesn't see
anything here where does the other arm
go it's still the same leg yeah today
it got where send it again
i still i'm still i still have my point
here right
but i i haven't finished i've drawn this
one arc but i need to draw another one
where do i draw it
where you think your other line that's
right so it's that's exactly right let
me repeat that again because no i said
exactly right
you draw another arc and i'm going to
draw up here
right because if a b is like this i'm
expecting my new line to sort of go
like this so it should hit through there
okay so draw another arc
um that
passes through
where you expect your new line to be
and because this a b i've actually drawn
it so it's quite parallel
right so this is horizontal sorry that's
what i mean
it's quite horizontal i'm expecting this
slide to go horizontal as well
okay that was step three what's step
four my compass point's going to go
somewhere else where is it going to go
would really help if we had some
language to describe this right
this point down here why don't we give
it a name what should we call it
a b c that seems like a logical choice
okay there's p
yeah but that's that's up above that's
doing its own thing so we'll do a q in a
second okay
so draw another arc so my next thing is
um
maybe i should say draw an arc that
intersects with a b
at c so that's what i'm calling it
so now i'm going to put my compass point
on c right place the compass point on c
now once i do that what am i going to do
where am i going to draw an arc uh do
you remember to intersect with
your arc that you escalated with not yet
not yet i gotta do something else first
i am going to get that but i think
that's the next step you know remember
there was another
arc i had to draw i'll show you it looks
like this how would you describe it oh
yeah that was the marking
how would you word that how would you
describe the step
it's gonna be step five draw an arc that
what
that's right draw an arc that intersects
with a b again
isn't it c and b
uh yes actually bc i guess
bc um what should we call that point
let's give it a name
good choice
okay now we're almost there okay
step six place the compass point on
d here
now what do i do with it where do i draw
it off
intersecting with the top
i'm gonna say draw an arc that
intersects with the arc from step three
because now we have language to describe
this right draw an arc that intersects
with the uh at step three
now by the way that point up there the
new one where these these two meet
it's alongside p so i'm going to call
that q
okay
i don't know okay last step step
join pqp
now mine's a little off i suspect um at
some point during that
i probably adjusted the width of my
compass a little bit but
there you go that's it you should look
at them
now my question to you is
why did it work why did it make
a parallel pair of lines
because i said but why but why
let me um let me draw something
something else
some more like you know lines onto your
intervals actually
and let me see if you can work out
what's going on with me have a look at
this
okay i just joined up
pc and qd
okay now why is a good question
okay i don't have a wire there but if i
did okay
now i'm just trying to point out to you
that this
shape p c d q
this shape is not just any shape it's a
very special shape and
if i had my previous other two here you
notice if i joined up the same ones
it'd be another special chain what kind
of shape
is it can you take it yeah parallelogram
okay number one
it's a parallelogram okay
that's the first event but it's actually
even more special than that remember
do you remember i kept on saying over
and over again i kept saying
make sure you don't change the length of
your compass do you remember i kept
saying that right
that means every time you drew an arc
it should be the same length the same
distance between the
center and the arm right so for instance
from here to here that distance
right that distance is the same as that
distance
do you agree yeah because i drew them
from the same point
then what did i do next hold on what did
i do next
i drew another r down here but i didn't
change the compass
yeah so it should still be the same
length right
yeah still the same length isn't it same
distance between the
compass point and the pencil right then
i drew one more i drew dq
but i didn't change the compass
so it should be the same length over
there
what kind of shape is this yes
it's equal animal when you've got a
quadrilateral
a four-sided figure and all the sides
are the same
don't know what's called starts with an
r a rhombus
we just you just drew a rhombus you
might like even to even join those lines
up
now we're going to spend a lot more time
talking about these kinds of figures
um in the future
but this is why this is why all of your
random
arcs and that kind of made parallel
lines because what it really made
was one of these okay and those sides
are parallel